who'll look after security in west
africa mali pulls out of the regional g5
sahad force blaming a lack of progress
and internal disagreements so is it time
for a new strategy to confront armed
groups
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum a founding member of a
multinational west african security
alliance is pulling out mali is part of
the g5 sahel joint force fighting armed
groups linked to isil and al-qaeda in
the region but the soldiers have
struggled to contain the violence mali's
military government blamed the
withdrawal decision on the lack of
progress and internal divisions it also
accused a country outside of the region
of trying to isolate mali without
providing details mali has come under
international pressure since the army
seized power in a coup in 2020. we'll
bring in our guests in a moment first
this report from nicholas hawk
mali says it no longer wants to be part
of a losing force five thousand soldiers
from burkina faso chad mali mauritania
and niger are in the g5 sahel it was
formed five years ago to combat armed
groups linked to isil and al-qaeda but
it's struggled to reduce attacks because
of lack of funding and disagreements
among member states mali was due to take
over as chair of the force in february
but opposition from member states
angered its military rulers
the opposition of some g5 saharan member
states to mali's presidency is linked to
two maneuvers by a state outside the
region aiming desperately to isolate
mali
mali's government accuses former
colonial power france of excluding it
once friends now foes the 5 000 french
troops deployed almost 10 years ago to
protect mali's government from attacks
are pulling out
after the military coup in 2020 leaders
of the genta hired russian mercenaries
from the wagner group for their
protection
the junta is refusing to hand over power
to civilian rule for another two years
as a result neighboring countries have
imposed sanctions on the landlocked
country sealing its borders and halting
trade prices have exploded for example
the price of soap has doubled and food
is much more expensive
basic necessities have become
unaffordable and this is because of the
embargo
if this continues we won't be able to
survive
this is unsustainable
state conference are becoming empty with
just enough to pay civil servants for a
few months togo has offered to mediate
between mali's junta and regional
leaders while the un peacekeeping force
remains the u.n secretary general warns
of the debilitating effect while these
troubles are having on the rest of the
region threatened by armed groups
ali is increasingly isolated with
russian mercenaries remaining to deal
with a country on the brink
nicholas hawke for inside story
all right let's take a look at the g5
sahel joint force it was formed in 2017
and has forces from mautenia mali niger
burkina faso and chad to counter armed
groups in the region
but it overlapped with existing mandates
from the u.n african union and the west
african regional bloc ikawes
that overlap meant all those
organizations competed for limited
financial and human resources
france supported the g5 and gave it
substantial military and financial
support but mali's military leaders have
asked paris to withdraw all its troops
and germany and the eu have reduced
their involvement in mali instead
focusing on you in operations
[Music]
all right let's bring in our guests in
mali's capital bamako neon koro yeh
samake
malian politician and president of the
party for civic and patriotic action
in freetown in sierra leone emmanuel
koise anning director of the research at
kofi annan international peacekeeping
training center
and in san malo in france jacqueline
senior research fellow at the global
policy institute a warm welcome to you
all and thanks so much for joining us
today on inside story yankora let me
start with you today so the spokesman
for mali's transitional government says
that the opposition of some g5 member
states tamale's presidency is linked to
maneuvers by a state outside the region
aiming to isolate mali
could you elaborate on that statement is
the spokesman referring to france or or
referring to another country
well um i would think for myself uh
of course in mali here we do believe
that there is
maneuvers from
the french government to isolate money
and for who knows the history of the
creation of the g-sync
g5
sahel
we do know that france has been a big
instigator of this the formula of this
organization in any way and also
advocating for funding for g5 style
so when we say that there are
non-member state influence uh we do know
because
chad has been assuming presidency for
the past years and the term ended in
february and as a rotating presidency
money world supposed to start assuming
presidency starting on february
following a meeting that never happened
so
we see this as a plot of the french
government to continue
to isolate man
emmanuel with molly pulling out of the
g5 joint force what does this mean for
security in west africa and and who
ultimately is now going to look out for
security in west africa
i think there's been
some sort of confusion
about what should be done relating to
the insecurities
faced by sahel and west african states
what we see a panoply or a conucopia of
acronyms representing its secret
institutions seeking to respond to
prevent and degrade
the threats that we are facing marley's
decision to withdraw
uh from the g5 sahel
for me it's a natural
continuation
of the
africanist
africa you know centric
miley centric policy that is janta seeks
to implement
now
i don't think this is going to be the
last step
after the
dismissal of the french from
mali
and other european troops
who had really never succeeded in
bringing security to money and i think
for me this is the bottom line that we
need to be clear
that those who sought to bring peace and
stability to marry themselves never
managed to do so
so
to seek to put the blame
on the gentiles as failing
and the presence of the wagner group
as contributing to the insecurity
i think is truly
a very weak argument
but the center itself
has not just come out of the door drops
it is the collective failure
of our sub-regional institutions
to crack the grip
relating to governments
that have voluntarily signed on
to our protocols and conventions in
which there were specific principles
invalid principles
that these previous governments violated
our regional organization simply just
kept quiet
so marley has become just a creeping boy
the collective failure of these
multinational institutions and because
they are
carrying on a pan-africanist agenda
backed by the you know some sections of
the populace
okay they are deliberate efforts
certainly led by france
through ecowas to undermine the efforts
ordinary
and i think
what is critical about the million
increasingly independent stance and
asserting a sovereignty is that we are
seeing such resistance as we chat
we are seeing it in aspects of nissan
emanuel i'm sorry emmanuel i'm sorry i'm
sorry to interrupt you uh let me get
back to that point you're making in just
a moment jacques let me ask you were you
surprised by molly's decision to leave
the g5 joint force and and from your
perspective is it time for some kind of
a new strategy to confront armed groups
no i was not surprised at all uh because
uh actually the g5 was almost uh dead or
as macron would have said about nato was
brain dead really now that mali had
stopped cooperating with the french uh
mali is at the core of uh at the
geographical and military
center
of this uh
this region where the need for
cooperation between the five states is
necessary in order to combat terrorism
and
uh
now that mali was not no longer
cooperating with the french it meant
that
the g5 had not much of a role anymore
the role of the g5
was to
provide to coordinate international help
to the region and also to help military
the armies of the region in their fight
against terrorism now that uh
when mali decided to go it alone uh it
was it became almost impossible to
achieve and we can see now that for
example
the cooperation the
mali has suffered from it and is
probably benefiting less from
international help than other region we
see that mali uh the position of mali is
very hard to understand for some people
they claim that is because france was
not successful against uh terrorism but
actually france as was fairly successful
did not manage to bring peace in the
area but it was not just due to the
french it was due to a failure of
governance on the part of the bamako
authorities leaving the north of the
region in the state of uh
really very poor administration and
great insecurity and uh military uh
physical and economic insecurity and
therefore uh at some point marie decided
it seems to the french that maybe malice
sees its role as being the leader of a
movement
kind of fighting the old colonial power
the presence of the west in the region
and especially the presence of france
and it seems to be wanting to fight an
anti-imperialist
fight
in which it would be helped by russia at
the wagner division which is more there
to protect the
malian junta than to protect malian
interest in my opinion and the opinion
of
many many experts so yeah no no surprise
at all you see that mali is carrying on
it's uh
in its uh approach to the situation
which is just to um accuse the
friendship
i'm sorry to interrupt you but i just
want to get a reaction i see nyankoro
you you you were reacting uh quite a lot
to what jacques was saying so so i want
to get your take go ahead and jump in
well you know quite frankly um you know
i just invite jack and like-minded
people to come to the understanding that
we are not um
fighting imperialism or anything we're
just claiming our
sovereignty
we just want respect in our relationship
with other nations uh following the
vienna convention
uh we don't want any other nation to
dictate we want to quit being the pre-k
of any nation on earth money wants to
stand up and look straight in the eyes
of the rest of the world as equals those
who want to keep us underneath
in the complex of superiority is not the
time has gone we have to consider money
as a nation we have to respect our
sovereign decisions to extend
partnership to other nations to fight
terrorism and this has come because
the current strategy
and the military doctrine the colonial
military doctrine that has been
implemented for nine years has failed
miserably failed we have to accept that
fact today within
less than five months
of
money breaking cooperation with french
military and asking for partnership
security situation has significantly
improved and this has been acknowledged
by uh the secretary general of the
united nations and other observers so we
have to come to an understanding france
is not the enemy of money
our position is we want to stand
straight we want to assume our
sovereignty and we want respect any
partner that would like to work within
the framework of respect
of our sovereignty is welcome to money
and we can work with any nation so
having said that
i think that we should put things into
context
mali has rightfully and with the support
of the people of mali
uh withdrawn from g5 which was uh to
begin with an absolute organization that
was never able to function because of
lack of funding lack of support of those
who initiated this organization there
have been pledges of money but which was
never mobilized for g5 which is
dysfunctional so let's
be clear what we don't do is just
stating that we want to reclaim our work
money was supposed to assume presidency
in february
and the
the conference of the heads of this g5
was supposed to meet here in bamako and
then transfer
the presidency to money it never
happened there was no explanation and so
it has become um a de facto absolute
organization so mali rightly withdrew
from g5 sahel
emmanuel uh let me ask you um the g5
sahel joint force has been fighting
armed groups linked to isil and al-qaeda
in the region but the soldiers have
struggled to contain the violence why
has it been
so difficult for the g5 sahaja joint
force
well look i think it's very basic
for training
limited logistics limited
interoperability
and always this perception of big
brother
looking down on the members of the team
and pulling their strengths and
controlling them like a marionette let
me go back a little bit and provide a
historical context
of why mali's decision to withdraw
is critical
malice behavior right now is almost
reminiscent
of dr chromos behavior in ghana in the
1950s and the early 60s leading to the
cia coup you know so what is happening
in mali
and and i'll say this very clearly
leaving the j5 sahel is
is going to be part of a continuum
of specific actions that agenda is going
to take
to reclaim mali's sovereignty
its identity
its sense of agency
and some of the fairly arrogant
responses coming out of paris
particularly the statement by the
defense minister
you know about
this disrespectful behavior
towards bamako
it's simply not acceptable
and i think you know she should read
this good poem the death of the wolf
in which basically the argument is that
silence is great and the rest is
weakness
you know those who seek to bring goats
to male
must be humble enough and to say how do
we listen
to another sovereign state
and i'm sure that we can partner and
collaborate
in a manner that locates the interest of
that partner
at the center of the condition
the malian people
in reading them the real act is not
going to help because when people talk
about the work in a group
the french legion did much worse
other countries of private military
companies have done worse in other parts
of the world and also on the african
continent for me
and a historical discussion about mali
is a disservice
both to international law
respect for human rights the rule of law
and also what the malian people truly do
want
jacques what's the relationship like
between mali and france right now and
where does that relationship go from
here
it's non-existent actually it's a
confrontational
uh
and it's uh it's a shame because there's
so many millions in france uh and we
have so many human links between the two
countries uh especially cultural links
and
there are two countries we
share
history even though it's a colonial
history but
lately actually france was more seen as
a helper army of liberation but
eventually it came to be seen as an army
of occupation but i think it's part of
a campaign which is spreading through
all of west africa and i would not maybe
ascertain it but can say that russian
cyber networks have had some influence
in whipping up anti-french feelings in
the area we've seen it in republic of
central africa where now uh since 2016
the wagner the russians are there and
helping themselves to all the mineral
resources diamonds and gold in the in
the north of central africa we see that
in mali they're trying to do the same we
can see that this
move towards
unsettling the french is also taking
place in senegal senegal which is a
region a country because it's not just
the sahel the terrorism there is
unsettling the whole region and going up
to the gulf of guinea and to the ivory
coast and it's kind of a settling
process and some people argue
we can't
you know but
definitely you know that
africa is a treasure chest everyone
wants in on africa and there's a reason
when you can see all the countries want
to be there in africa china
russia
turkey the arab america
everyone wants to be able to help
themselves to the mineral resources of
africa and therefore
want to take the place of the colonizer
the colonialists and in the case of west
africa france and in part in nigeria and
ghana it was britain but france has
remained as retained close links which
is extraordinary
dependencies which makes it the idol
culprit and
in spite of its efforts to break with
it's true france has exploited africa
for a long time but since then there's
been a trying to rebalance the
relationship between the countries and
and france is no longer the same as it
was uh even 10 years ago there's been
big changes since hollywood and uh and
macron and therefore it's that's why uh
that's why the french are worried it's
part of you know mali is just a small
piece in a much bigger game which is all
about uh
some countries wanting to exert the
influence on very weak governments
whatever uh people say the uh
we are really starting to run out of
time uh nyankoro let me ask you i i it
looks like you want to react to some of
what jacques was saying i'll let you do
that but also i want to ask you about
the fact that mali's military government
is also saying that its security forces
toward it an attempted coup led by army
officers and supported by an unnamed
western state what more do you know
about that and and where does the
investigation into it stand
well it just um it's
beyond
frustrating
that many people have not come to the
understanding that we are
leading to
a new era of world order
that we cannot
continue
to exploit
people
and countries like france has been doing
in africa for so many years the time has
come where the people are determined
to
assume their sovereignty and once you
engage in the course of sovereignty
there is no way back france will gain
a lack to
change its attitude
from this paternalistic attitude to a
partnership
and equal to equal partnership the whole
world is converging towards africa 21st
century is going to be africa's time
so france should position itself to be a
part of it instead of being excluded
from it and start this arrogant behavior
that you know we did this for africa
africa did work for france you should
also become that but
coming to
answering your question
yes there was an attempted coup
uh but as i have always told uh
president assimilita
our number one refuge is not
in behind organizations or other nations
behind our people we love the way mali
is being led today we have never been so
proud in our country to be standing tall
to be assuming and exhorting our
sovereignty
but we do believe that france has
declared that it will destabilize and
has many instances trying to isolate
money so we take france by its own words
so their intent is to take down
our
uh military leaders
but with the protection of the people
they will fail and when they take one
man out ten men will stand up in that
state so this is not a matter of one man
this is a matter of a nation
understanding and having a desire to
free ourselves from the french control
from the french colonialism from the
colonial doctrine of
taking our or loading our resources
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests nian coro yes
emanuel
and jacqueline
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website alzheimer.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad i'm joining the whole team here
bye for now